hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the women's section of the
American Cup we've seen what happened in
the game between ahikaru and and Wesley
writer in the match between Hikaru and
Wesley Hikaru won that very nicely and
now it's time to check out what happened
in the matchup Alice Lee versus Irina
Crush now the two classical games they
have played have ended in a draw and
they had to take it to tie breaks but
what's interesting is what happened in
the second classical game and this is
the position from the second classical
game this is move 56 uh Alice has the
white pieces and King the F5 was just
played so I just wanna briefly mention
what happened here before we check out
the actual rapid game so here King 25
was played and Alice had a winning um
maneuver here and you can win this many
different ways you can play King to D7
you can play King to B7 you can play
Rook to B3 and go for Rook to B8 but she
didn't she went for Rook the A5 check
instead the thing is after King to B7
White's winning of course uh everyone
realizes that you can promote the spawn
to a queen and the black will have to
give up The Rook but the the question is
will the white rook and king be able to
stop Black's uh two connected past pawns
now let's check out this Rook to G8 Rook
the A8 and now Rook the G7 pinning The
Pawn King to B6 and now Rook captures on
C7 you have to take it otherwise uh
White just gets a queen into the game so
King captures on C7 and now Pawn to E5
and now can you stop the pawns King to
D6 Ponte E4 and now Rook the f8 check
and white is indeed in time to save the
pawns
um from queening so King to G4 uh King
to E5 and now Ponta F3 let's say it
doesn't really matter what you play
because either this Pawn is falling or
this Pawn is falling or you advance this
Pawn then will captures an F4 uh so
let's say Pawn to F3 uh can be played
King captures any four and you cannot
Advance the pawn further as The Rook
would just gobble it up here you're
gonna gobble it up whatever a black
plays so it was possible for her to win
the game but like I said she played Rook
day 5 checking the E4 was played uh King
to G4 was a draw King the E4 is still
winning for Alice but she again has to
play King to B7 or King to D7 but she
went for King to D6 and this is just
another two valuable uh tempo for for
Irina uh to start advancing her own Pawn
now Rook to E5 with checking the D3 Rook
captures was played Rook captures on C7
now giving up the Rogue because the pawn
is now Unstoppable King captures F2 Rook
to F6 and now King to E2 and here they
just traded King D6 with King to D3 Rook
to F6 King T2 now comes Rook D6 checking
the D3 and after Rook F6 King T2 and
Rook D6 they agreed to draw or rather
it's a draw by a three-fold repetition
uh so that's what happened in the second
game of the classical time format and
now we go into the fourth game or rather
the second game of the rapid time format
here uh uh yeah Alice has the black
pieces uh in the first rapid game uh
Irina had the black pieces and she
defeated Alice uh it was a really wild
end game uh Irina had four pieces for uh
for four points for a piece and she was
able to outplay Alice in the end game
and now it's Alice with the black pieces
she's in a must win situation if she
wants the uh for Blitz tie breaks so
let's see what happened uh in this one
so uh Edina has the white pieces and she
opens with the D4 we have D5 by Alice C4
E6 Knight to C3 and now Bishop to E7
going for the child of SEC A variation
of the Queen's Gambit declined C capture
Sunday 5e captures and the bishop to F4
we have Knight to F6 Ponte E3 and now
usually you will just see castles or
Bishop to F5 here Alice goes Bishop back
to D6 it's an incredibly rare line only
been played once and uh well probably
meant to to confuse Arena and uh give
her a position that she maybe isn't as
familiar with to create some winning
Chances with black so here there is one
game where best of G5 was played with
Queen to F3 and it is now as of move 7
that we have a completely new game so
okay Ponta C6 with Bishop to D3 castles
uh and now Ponte H3 stopping this bishop
to G4 move Knight to the A6 remanuvering
the Knight the C7 uh and Knight G2 E2 we
have knifed the C7 and pawn to G for now
Arena goes after the
uh Castle the black king Knights the E6
and now a queen side castles and um okay
black might not be a spectacular here or
rather black is uh I mean perfectly
perfectly fine here but at least the
Alice got uh what you wanted she wanted
an imbalanced position where chances are
um for both sides it's possible to play
for a win with both and that's exactly
what you wanted so here Ponta B5 she
starts advancing her Queen side pawns
and Irina does the same only on the king
Side Pawn to G5 Knights the E8 and pawn
to H4 we have Pawn to B4 Knight to A4
and now Queen to A5 going for the Knight
here with B3 and Bishop to D7 hoping to
get some C5 and Bishop captures an A4 in
we have King to B1 getting the King off
of the C file you know that this Rook is
coming to the C file and now only now
Knight captures on F4 we have Knight
captures and now Knight the C7 uh and
this Knight the C7 is a bit um too
ambitious of a move you should have gone
back with the queen as the queen really
overstay their welcome on A5 but now you
have to find the correct winning idea
for white and it's not um it's not an
easy move to find so if you guys want to
try feel free to pause the video and try
to find a crushing idea here for Irina
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible uh move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is either Queen to H5 although Knight to
H5 is much much stronger and now there's
just no defense Knight captures on G7
and Knight to F6 check both will be
crushing for white even if you stop it
with some like Bishop D7 still Knights
the F6 with check and now uh Bishop
captures an F6 you're gonna play G
captures and F6 G6 and now Rook D to G1
the thread is Queen H5 Queen H6 and
queen to G7 Checkmate so we're gonna put
a knight to the E8 to cover the G7
square but now H5 is coming and uh
there's no defense Queen to d8 You're
Gonna Play H captors H captors Queen to
H5 and that's it either you're getting
checkmated on H7 or on h8 if if for
example you play Knight captures to
cover the H7 Square you get a queen to h
a Checkmate and if you capture with the
queen to cover the h8 square you get
Queen to H7 Checkmate but this is only a
few of them there are many more
checkmating ideas that happen after
Knight to H5 but she missed it she
played Rook to C1 I think here she was
already maybe in the mindset of just not
losing instead of um trying to win as
she already won the first game so now
she only needs a draw to win the match
uh Knight to B5 now Knight H5 again
possible but they are both ignoring it
Knight the E2 and now Rook 8 to B8 we
have Ponte H5 now comes Knight to C3
with check trying everything to break
through here on the queen side Knight a
captures on c3b captures and now even
Rook captures on C3 you could just
ignore this and play H6 but um uh like I
said probably the the mindset thing with
Bishop the B4 going after the rook and
now only Now Pawn to H6 and now uh White
is completely winning uh here the
problem is if you capture on C3 then
there's this very nasty Bishop captures
an H7 check and that's the that's the
main idea behind
H6 and now after King captures H captors
and G7 with check from The Rook on H1 a
nice Discovery King captures Queen F6
checking G8 and now Rook to h8 or queen
to h8 will be Checkmate so instead after
H6 F5 was played but uh it's
insufficient each captures and G7 Rook
F7 and now uh getting the Rook out of
Harm's Way Rook the C2 now comes Rook
captures on G7 Knights the G3 and now
Bishop to C3 trying uh a very tricky
idea here if if Irina goes for some like
Knight captures an F5 then Rook captures
and B3 is the idea if Pawn captures then
Rook a queen to A1 will be Checkmate so
after Bishop to C3 just Rook captures on
C3 giving back a little bit of material
but um it's perfectly fine Queen
characters on C3 and now Bishop the C2
with Rook to F7 uh if you go for Rook to
G5 then you run into this nasty Queen to
F4 attacking both of the Rooks uh so
instead Rook to F7 a rook Dev seven was
played and now Knight to H5 a few moves
uh later but uh still with the deadly
purpose the Knight is now coming to F6
so King to f8 avoiding the fork uh
Knight to F6 attacks the bishop and King
E7 defending the bishop and also trying
to run away with the king queen to F for
re-maneuvering the queen to E5 by
attacking The Rook on B8 with Rook the
B7 and now Queen to E5 with check King
38 and now Pawn to G6 breaking through
uh now if captures then just Rook to h8
to check so Rook to E7 was played
attacking the queen but the just the G
captures on H7 leaving the queen hanging
here as you will get another queen uh
once the pawn reaches the h8 square so
Rook captures an E5 have the characters
on E5 there's no Russian uh getting
another queen with King to C7 and now h8
with queen and now uh Alice is just down
material she's done a full night plus
also here her King is vulnerable plus
also well there's just all the stuff on
the board but she will still of course
try Ponte A5 her dream now is to get
this Pawn all the way to A3 and check
materina with Queen to B2 so is there uh
any Merit to this idea Knight captures
on D7 Pawn to A4 now uh not even
borrowing with capturing back the knight
uh we have Queen to G7 threatening some
nasty discoveries and now Pawn to A3
threatening Checkmate here and that's
basically all you could do because you
know your white is winning here it's
merely a matter of maybe white doesn't
win and then you get to Checkmate the
the white king and B2 but of course
Irina spots it as there are many winning
ideas uh uh but uh the the this one is
the nicest one and that is nice the C5
with the check now if you go back of
course a rook to h8 will be Checkmate so
King the B6 was played but now comes
Knight to a for check and he was in this
position animal 41 that Alice Lee
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once the king moves
doesn't really matter where you're gonna
lose the queen even better you could
play Queen captures and B7 with check
and then just gobble up the queen and
black has absolutely zero counter play
here so it doesn't matter how you play
you are of course completely winning but
yeah incredible stuff uh Alice really
went all out but in the end
Irina takes the the women's section of
the of the American Cup uh first two
games like I said In classical
crushed Alice in both of the rapid games
uh so yeah tough break for Alice who was
uh winning in that uh position like we
mentioned in the classical game here
after King to F5 she didn't find it she
didn't find uh King B7 or King to D7 I
probably thought that the two pawns will
be able to over overtake the look uh but
um it was in fact winning so she came
close but Grandmaster Irina Crusher is
the one who emerges Victorious uh so
yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it uh both of the demand section
and the women's section Hikaru takes the
men's section Irina takes the women's
section I would like to thank a very
nice video yesterday Ryan Kavanaugh
Henry Spraggins Richard carp and Lauren
Andre um janessini for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day